déconneur
tourneur sur bois depuis 11 ans déjà
revenant la réunion après un séjour de
huit en métropole en toc fraser comment
numérique pas moyen de trouver du
travail dans le fraisage en tout cas à
la réunion il n'ya pas vraiment ça et
finalement j'ai dû me recycler dans le
bois est aujourd'hui je suis vraiment
sur
épanouie dans ceux de ce que je fais
quoi en fin de compte parce que j'aime
ce que je fais j'ai l'amour du bois et
je connais pas mal d'essence maintenant
avec le temps je suis tout dans la
nature aussi vous dire donc la nature et
moir l'on travaille ensemble quoi
finalement donc alors les pièces que je
fais c'est plutôt destiné à la table à
la cuisine entre topo la table il ya des
bols et assiettes complément gels et
bien sûr de dormance effet pour des
pilons si vous la cuisine sa tradition
des bals postale aller tout ça donc je
fais aussi sur commande des pièces je
réalise les pièces selon les commandants
ce qu'il veut le client vraiment en moi
j'écoute pas du bois vers moi
personnellement je vais la tuer je vais
récolter prélever du bois mort carrément
pourra travailler avec lui en fait la
coupe se fait à la tronçonneuse et après
il ya un petit parti l'assise de la
pièce justement que je pense à un peu
quand même pour avoir un parti liste
proposée sur le plateau du tour ou avoir
une stabilité sur le tour qu'on fait et
on peut pivoter de lax du tour jusqu'à
la gauche aux données les formes au
creuset ont fait la partie avec serial
plus souvent d'abord et après on vient
pas à l'intérieur c'est la partie finale
avant le passage pour usiner la pièce il
faut que l'outil elles soient bien
tranchant c'est ça qui fait toute la
partie de l'usinage enfin parce que si
l'outil elle est pas bien tranchante on
va prendre beaucoup de temps on va pas
enlever les copeaux on va plutôt
arracher la matière en coupe pas
vraiment il faut qu'une bonne si
tranchants et là on travaille bien on
prend moins de temps c'est un question
de gain de temps tout ça aussi et le
travail dans des bonnes conditions les
petites finitions lieu le fait à la main
on se retourne la pièce du tout en fait
je le fais en faisant en frottant un peu
avec un pv à prendre en compte pour
avoir une bonne vraiment une bonne
finition on sait prête à l'emploi déjà
là elle sort du tour
juste dépoussiérer puis on peut mettre à
table décoration les sens essentiel que
je travaille notamment le jacques lebas
noir l'olive l'eucalyptus aussi je
travaillais rouge surtout parce que le
blanc est vraiment exploitable après il
ya le copo le congo carrément jean luck
offriez convient d'usiné là vous avez
senti l'odeur des gens c'est agréable ça
débouche les narines les bronches et
tout ça ça devient demi finales d'une
part et c'est agréable aussi à
travailler question dureté un densité de
bois du coup ben je prends un plaisir de
travailler parce que c'est facile c'est
agréable là comme vous voyez j'ai deux
tamarins qu'est ce que peuvent je
préfère aussi un travail et le tamarin
parce qu'il est noble c'est un bois
devient ici comme je la leur alors
notamment la commune a travaillé le camp
sud a lancé dans la même forme dans les
faits coucher toujours ça c'est de
l'olive qu'ont nos grands-parents et
prenez pour balayer les cours à bec ou
s'ils ne le prenez aussi pour guise de
rameau pour aller à la messe
le livre s'est taillé la voisine quand
même là cette taille là est la voisine
quand même plus d'une cinquantaine
d'années parce que sachant que ça pousse
dans les rivières beaucoup de lumière et
célébra c'est le trait dans son bois
barcelo a poussé et j'aime bien les
défauts naturel alors ce que je cherche
moi dans la nature ses déboires avec
plein trouble dans 20 des mictions
rentrer dedans en fait c'est la nature
inquiète et qui a travaillé le bois
avant moi je fais que donner la forme
après un dut mettre en valeur les
défauts naturel finalement bien vous
voyez un peu les trous là qu'il ya
dedans et justement c'est ce que j'aime
je préfère le plus mes clients aussi
d'ailleurs et on garde son côté naturel
quoi finalement s est hissé la pièce
unique en fait
là